[Music]
on this Sunday night the eve of the
historic State funeral for Queen
Elizabeth II the hundreds of dignitaries
Canadians mourning her loss who feel
like they've lost a family member and
the Public's final chance to pay their
respects rattled and running for their
lives the earthquake that shook Taiwan
an SOS for 9-1-1 obviously we need to
change something the pleas to rescue
Canada's struggling ambulance system and
Empire of corgis
the Queen's Devotion to these adorable
doggies
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight from London
good evening thank you for joining us
tonight at Westminster Abbey behind me
and all along the streets of Central
London final preparations have been
underway all day for one of the most
grand and solemn events in recent
history but not too long ago
2 000 guests will file into the historic
building behind me where Queen Elizabeth
II was married crowned and where her
life will be celebrated tomorrow among
the guests the leaders of almost every
country and royalty from all around the
world it's difficult to remember a time
that there have been so many dignitaries
in one place tonight they were hosted at
Buckingham Palace for what's being
called the reception of the century our
coverage begins tonight with Redmond
Shannon who has a new statement from the
King Redmond
Pharaoh we are just hours away now from
an event perhaps unlike anything this
country has seen before and just a short
time ago King Charles III issued a
statement to people of the UK and around
the world in it he said he wanted to say
thank you to all those countless people
who have been such a support and comfort
to my family and myself in this time of
greed she had that look like
are you okay anything I can do for you
what do you need and then also make sure
you do what you're supposed to do these
heads of government and foreign royals
here in London including Ukraine's first
lady Elena zelenska police outside
Westminster Hall shutting down
intersections all day as VIPs come to
pay their respects one invited leader
who reportedly won't be coming to the
funeral is Saudi Arabia's Muhammad bin
Salman the busy schedule continues for
the new King Charles hosting a reception
for leaders and dignitaries at
Buckingham Palace and from the new Queen
consort Camilla recalling the very
different era when Elizabeth became
Queen it must have been so difficult for
her being a solitary woman now what
women Prime Ministers or women
presidents um she was the only one so I
think she carved her own role for
members of the public who still wish to
see the queen lying in state time is
running out the cube is being closed on
on Sunday those at the end of it right
now expected to reach Westminster Hall
in the early hours of Monday morning
it rush to be part of History before
it's too late okay all this far I will
make it I have faith I'll make it if I
don't make it I wouldn't forgive myself
I've been very sensibly down
turn around very fast so now we're gonna
hot foot it we're about ready for the
elements we've got a little backpack
ready to go that line has now closed the
doors of Westminster Hall will shut at 6
30 a.m local time and just over four
hours after that the procession begins
to Westminster Abbey for the funeral
pharah
Redmond Shannon here in London tonight
thank you Redmond
prime minister Justin Trudeau sat down
with his UK counterpart in a handful of
other leaders today our Abigail Beemans
traveling with the Canadian delegation
and joins us now Abigail Farah this trip
is focused on the queen but it's also
remarkable to have so many world leaders
in one place so the Prime Minister began
his day meeting with the Australian
prime minister before heading to 10
Downing Street the famous 10 Downing
Street cat Larry getting more exposure
to world leaders this weekend as so many
Gather in London ahead of the Queen's
funeral it started obviously with
sympathies and condolences for for all
of our loss Justin Trudeau had his first
meeting with new UK prime minister Liz
truss we talked a fair bit about trade
about the Canada UK trade agreement that
is continuing in its negotiations to
find a permanent bilateral trade deal
that is advancing well but Trudeau says
Ukraine topped the agenda he met with
Ukraine's prime minister Sunday too
though he wouldn't say whether Canada
will offer more concrete Aid the Prime
Minister also attended multiple events
not on his public itinerary and closed
to Media Stephen Harper was invested
into the Order of Canada in front of all
the other former Prime Ministers and
governors General on the trip later King
Charles hosted a reception for world
leaders on the eve of his mother's
funeral great example of the sense of
Duty
and doing the job that you have to do
for the public with great dignity
that's why she is respected in every
part of the world it's a big loss for
everybody to represent the Order of
Canada a huge honor Olympian Mark
Tewksbury is part of the Canadian
delegation and the funeral procession
Queen has brought so many of us together
and it just reminds you of her her reach
and her power and her beautiful service
it's a goodbye on a grand scale uniting
everyone from average Canadians who
traveled here to line the route to the
official delegation to heads of state
and people from right around the globe
Farah
Abigail Beeman here in London tonight
thank you Abigail
and we caught up with the Canadian who
just found out he will be inside
Westminster Abbey tomorrow Lieutenant
Colonel Mark Flint of the North Shore
New Brunswick regiment says it will be
an honor of a lifetime to attend the
funeral of his commander-in-chief
I was a very late addition to the
process and uh you know I'm I'm so
thankful that it was me and I think on a
personal note I actually grew up in
England and I emigrated to Canada in
1975. so for me and and certainly my
mother she is thinking very deeply about
this moment and that I'm here so I
facetimed her last night and she was
very emotional and teary and you know
she grew up here for all of her life and
and she's 78 now and so like so many
britons have said on their interviews
over the last few days she's the only
queen that she's ever known and so to
have her son here um yeah it's an
immense uh point of Pride for her
and just a reminder the Queen's State
funeral is in several hours our Donna
Friesen is going to Anchor our live
coverage tomorrow starting at 5 a.m
Eastern 2 A.M Pacific here on global
television globalnews.ca and on all our
other streaming platforms
after Hurricane Maria flattened it five
years ago Puerto Rico's power grid has
been left in a fragile state coming up
the new storm spawning new problems plus
one every second matters Canadian
ambulance response times hit a crisis
point
security cameras caught this terrifying
moment in Taiwan the ceiling at this gym
collapsed forcing badminton players to
Run for Cover as a powerful 6.8
earthquake along with aftershocks rocked
the country's East the Quake toppled a
three-story building collapsing roads
trapping hundreds of tourists on a
Mountainside and causing a passenger
train to derail
and breaking news out of Puerto Rico
where hurricane Fiona is battering the
Caribbean island already knocking out
power to the entire U.S territory the
storm is packing Fierce winds clocking
130 kilometers an hour and triggering
flash floods it's feared Fiona will also
bring record rain and mudslides pianos
already devastated the French territory
of Guadalupe killing at least one person
in an emergency every second matters and
when you call 9-1-1 you'd hope an
ambulance arrives in minutes
unfortunately that's not always the case
with the pressures in Canada's Health
Care System stretching Beyond hospitals
as Heather York's West explains
Advocates say the remedy for that is a
revamp
[Applause]
September 10th Calgary a youth hockey
tryout and a player takes a difficult
hit as a dad watching and you're hoping
that he can get up he didn't get up
right away he wasn't moving August 6th
New Westminster BC an 81 year old former
city councilor suffers a stroke 9-1-1 is
called right away luckily there were
some friends with her and one was a
doctor but when save a Brar and Lori
Williams needed the help of an ambulance
it wasn't there Seva just 14 waited on
the ice for more than an hour before the
fire department responded instead and
while an ambulance eventually came for
Williams it was two hours before she
reached a hospital just a few blocks
away she's been left partially Paralyzed
by her stroke well obviously we need to
change something right like this is not
just in Calgary this is Canada wide
paramedics across the country agree
ambulances are struggling to get to
calls as fast as they should in every
Province and territory bystanders are
awaiting an extraordinary long time for
paramedics to get to scene because we're
tied up in hospitals we're seeing this
with people who have fallen hip
fractures we're seeing the elderly
suffer it's a symptom of a health system
in crisis across the board after more
than two years of covet health workers
are burnt out Staffing levels are
falling just as demand for care is on
the rise the numbers are coming up in
all areas I think people in Mental
Health crisis certainly some of the
addiction crisis are standing out but
it's in general it's all types of calls
are coming up Advocates say Canada's
health system is in need of an emergency
overhaul a restructuring to meet the
needs of an aging population dealing
with an escalated crisis of addictions
and mental health remember the system
was built in the 60s
the 60s and today's as two different
kind of Worlds it is important that we
consider an increase in funding but
funding is not just the only solution
but Solutions are needed now with a
potentially tough flu season poised to
add more pressure to a system unable to
cope Heather urich's West Global News
Calgary
the master ceremony was supposed to go
to the mic
[Music]
ahead when former prime minister Jean
chratia was left singing and sweating
before her majesty
prime minister Justin Trudeau's own
connection to the queen is a little
closer than most Trudeau has known her
personally since he was a child when his
father Pierre LED Canada earlier I spoke
with the PM and his wife Sophie on how
they're remembering the late Monarch and
what's next for their relationship with
the new king
Mr Prime Minister you have known the
queen since you were five years old
you've said she was one of your favorite
people are there any defining stories or
moments that really stand out to you her
steady presence throughout my life and
her very active presence this last these
past seven years was just a constant
there was no surprises with her I knew
any time I came to meet her she would be
incredibly gracious and thoughtful and
curious and engaged I remember that she
was so present the Integrity of her
presence that deep reassurance of being
there of being present and of deep
listening her late Majesty's Reign was
so incredibly powerful from a female
leadership point of view and I celebrate
that we all know her from you know
waving on the balcony at Buckingham
Palace but you two both got to meet her
behind closed doors a lot of people talk
about her her wit and her sense of humor
can you tell me a bit about that first
of all she was an extraordinarily
gracious in that whenever she met anyone
she was focused on what that moment
needed to be and it always needed to be
her there and present
and her ability to do that to hit the
right Mark to hit the right tone to
connect with people the right way means
that yes we knew her from having
directed interact with it but the people
lining the streets outside Canadians you
know mourning her loss who feel like
they've lost a family member are not
wrong because they knew her too because
if you watched her publicly if you heard
her speak you knew her because she was
genuinely the person that she'd share
publicly you've also known the king for
for a long time and you met with him
yesterday what were your impressions of
him now that he's in this role
he is going to be steady and engaged and
thoughtful like his mother was
he knows Canada very well he spent such
time there he's been you know active on
protecting the planet on engaging with
people around the world he's very
interested in indigenous reconciliation
there's a lot of good work to do that he
is going to be able to to lead in in the
within the limits and and the position
he has but I think his commitment to
listening engaging learning
embodying a you know
thoughtful generational path forward
speaking about the indigenous issue many
indigenous people in Canada have a less
favorable view of the crown do you think
the monarchy is an impediment to
reconciliation no I think it's a
powerful tool for reconciliation it's
got to be a part of of of the path
forward appointing the first indigenous
governor general for example was a key
step forward in reconciliation having a
king who is making deliberate efforts to
learn to understand to to embody a new
relationship with indigenous peoples
that we're developing as a country is
essential we have new polling that shows
that the majority of Canadians think
it's time to move on from the monarchy
given that and given that times have
changed is it not the time to begin at
least a national conversation on that I
think Canadians
vastly and majoritarily appreciate the
stability of our democracy we are able
to have all the strength of debates that
we need to have in Canada without
worrying about the overarching stability
of Institutions because they are
embodied by structures that have been in
place for for hundreds of years
Canadians have been through a lot of
constitutional wranglings over the past
decades I think the appetite for what it
would take when there are so many big
things to focus on is simply a
non-starter how are you feeling today
how are you at this moment and it must
be
so big for you and I think it's it's a
moment as well where we know how fast
everything moves and how complicated how
troubled the world is right now taking a
moment to position ourselves in the
sweep of History this is a moment to
take stock to reflect on where we're
going on what we're focusing on and how
we continue to be there for each other
in a world that is changing but still
has symbols of steadiness that we can we
can anchor ourselves Chuck Mr Prime
Minister Madam Gregoire Trudeau thank
you for your time Q
former prime minister John cretier also
shared a special bond with her majesty I
had a chance to speak with him as well
today and he shared with us a story
about the time he was forced to sing in
front of her and in front of a crowd of
thousands of people at an event
the master ceremony was about to go to
the mic
and saying Oh Canada but a guy was too
nervous so he turned to me he said I
cannot do that
so the Call of Duty I got up and moved
to the mic
but I started to single Canada in French
and nobody came along
I was sweating my wife said she'd never
been so shy in her life and when I met
the queen after that I said you're she
was laughing and I said your majesty
very few Canadians and I've been
soulless for the royal family but don't
ask me to sing at this moment you will
know why she was laughing
corgis of the crown next the history
behind the Queen's famous Little Friends
it's no secret just how much the queen
loved corgis over her 70-year Reign
she's believed to have owned dozens of
the adorable dogs and still had a few
under her care before she died Jeff
sempel looks at the long history of her
furry Royal companions
pembrokeshire in Western Wales is known
for its stunning Coastline and
Countryside but the county is perhaps
most famous for its four-legged
residents
the Pembroke Welsh Corgi these cute
curious cattle herding dogs originated
here in pembrokeshire they're so they're
so lovely
come on this couple has been breeding
corgis for a decade including plenty of
prize pooches how many do you have here
now one or two
they recently sold one named Vicky to a
Canadian near Toronto now on her way to
becoming a champion and some of Vicki's
cousins live in London this particular
breed called Welsh Corgi pembrokes are a
little bit smaller than other breeds and
as you might have recognized they've
also enjoyed a lifelong friendship with
royalty
almost everywhere the queen went her
contingent of corgis wasn't far behind
her first name Susan was a present for
her 18th birthday over six decades she
owned more than 30 of Susan's
descendants a royal doggy Dynasty she
just had too many dogs the Queen's
animal psychologist says she had
remarkable control over her corgis but
when she left things could get rough the
dogs were known for nipping at people's
ankles and getting into terrible tussles
I did say your mom possibly got too many
dogs you know and she said talk to
Mumford yeah Philip has been telling me
that for years and if I wanted to hear
that I I wouldn't have paid you to come
help me out and So eventually she heeded
that advice at the end the queen owned
just a couple of corgis they're now
living with prince Andrew
asked how the dogs are doing William
said they're just fine
these pembrokeshire pups once considered
an endangered breed are now thriving
thanks in no small part to their famous
best friend but it's hard to imagine
this place without them
Jeff sample Global News London